who are your influences for stannis
baratheon is he based on anyone from
history literature or politics to some
extent he is inspired by Tiberius Caesar
not necessarily did Tiberius Caesar from
history but to a great extent by
Tiberius Caesar as portrayed by God I'm
blanking on the actor's name Baker I
believe in I Claudius incredible British
TV series like Claudius George Baker I
believe it was yes played Tiberius in
that and there are significant
differences too but that series if you
haven't seen I Claudius it's it's one of
the great historical television series
of all time incredible acting by Sean
Phillips as Libya and of course there at
Jacobi as as Claudius himself and John
Hurt is in it as Caligula Brian Blessed
as Augustus all of them got an enormous
amount of acclaim for their portrayals
and deservedly show the writing was also
amazing based on the the Robert Graves
book but you know the scripting was was
terrific George Baker though was a very
important character in the first six or
so episodes and he doesn't seem to get
the acclaim that the other people got
and I think he really should his
Tiberius was was terrific so that was at
least one inspiration but they're not at
all the same character but they do share
certain certain characteristics